c'est l'un des arbitres les plus
prometteurs de france gabriel henry 22
ans a découvert l'arbitrage il y à 7 ans
alors qu'il était gardien de but et
éducateur au voisin football club
on m'a demandé de dépanner sur un
tournoi d'être arbitre pour le club et
ça m'a vachement plus et donc c'est
comme ça qui est venue cette idée de
l'arbitré après le club à inscrire la
formation initiale et j'ai commencé j'ai
commencé le premier match en district
comme ça du district des yvelines à la
france entière
gabriel a gravi les échelons au fil des
années il est aujourd'hui arbitre
principal en nationale 2 4e division
nationale il apprend également aux côtés
des plus expérimentés moi j'observe
beaucoup les arbitres qui sont plus
expérimentés que moi que ce soit au
dessus en liga ou ou même en au même
niveau que moi j'ai la chance de faire
4e aussi à 4éme arbitre en ligue 2 et
donc là c'est le moment où j'apprends le
plus parce que je vois une approche
professionnelle de l'arbitrage et pour
moi c'est juste différent riche histoire
même s'il a déjà plusieurs rencontres de
haut niveau à son actif une seule lui
vient en tête lorsqu'on lui demande son
plus beau souvenir forcément mon plus
beau souvenir c'est la finale de la
coupe gambardella 2019 que j'ai la
chance de faire au centre au stade de
france
donc devant un petit paquet de monde
c'était c'était assez sympa entre donc
c'était toulouse contre saint-etienne ce
jour là il prépare sa rencontre du
week-end un match de ligue 2 entre le
havre et sochaux où il officiera en tant
que quatrième arbitre
quant à ses objectifs il ne s'en fixe
pas pour le moment je vais déjà prendre
chaque match après chaque match comme
comme disent les joueurs de foot et puis
non c'est simplement c'est surtout de
prendre du plaisir parce que l'arbitrage
avant tout c'est pour moi c'est du
plaisir c'est une passion j'ai mes
études de kiné à côté donc ses salles à
la priorité après l'arbitrage c'est pour
moi c'est juste que du bonheur donc
temps que je peux continuer à pratiquer
je continuerai la crise sanitaire n'a
pas changé la routine d'entraînement du
jeune arbitre
bien que le championnat de nationale 2
soit actuellement suspendu